looking at myself honestly John says I'm
deeply envious and resentful of others
happiness how do I turn this around well
John I would say you've started to turn
it on around already because you have at
least come to the conclusion that you're
deeply envious and resentful of others
happiness so you do have the damn
problem diagnosed so one of the things
you might do is figure out what you
would like instead like how would you
like to feel about the world you know
because you're implying that being
deeply envious and resentful isn't for
the best so let's assume that you would
rather be pleased up about other
people's successes and not envious well
you know the first thing you might think
is well maybe you have to do some
writing or at least some thinking it's
like maybe the alternative would be to
happy be happy about others success and
happiness well maybe you should start by
thinking about why you might be happy
about their happiness it's not like
happiness is a zero-sum game you know
it's not like it's not and I believe me
I'm taking your question seriously and I
think that what you're saying
characterizes plenty of people and I
think that you're being deeply honest
noticing it happiness isn't a zero-sum
game you know lots of people can be
happy at the same time and do you really
want to live in a world where other
people are less happy would in what
possible manner would that be useful and
good for you in the medium to long term
it might make you feel you know
grudgingly satisfied you know in a dark
way temporarily but it's not a very good
long-term strategy so I would say you
got to think it through you know what
how is it that you would like to view
the world how do you think that would be
best for you
I mean as if you were taking care of
yourself like you like you're someone
who deserves to be taken care of think
about how you'd like to have the world
how you'd like to view the world and one
of the ways you can do that too is to
think about some people that you admire
and try to figure out how they look at
the world or even ask them you know
because maybe then you can find out what
it is about your thought patterns that
are driving
you down this sort of dark road